yes it's terrible news um it's always um
so heart rendering when we hear about
people who have lost their lives at our
closed and militarized borders and
whether at the uk or around europe it's
a disaster and it has to mark a point of
change for this government in their
approach to refugees right and change in
what way what would what is the way to
to stop this in your view
well we just heard very disappointingly
from the prime minister that his
intention is to just plow on with the
same failed approach that we've been
pursuing for 30 years
and it obviously hasn't worked people
won't disappear behind another round of
spending on board offenses and
securitization
when we try to close down routes for
people to seek asylum all we do is lose
control of the situation and hand it
over to the smugglers this government's
new bill that's in front of parliament
right now is complicit with the
smugglers who are bringing people across
the channel
it this is the time for the government
to stop turn around completely change
their approach pull its head out of the
sand and give people ways to travel to
the uk for the purpose of seeking asylum
safely take them out of the hands of
those smugglers but does the prime
minister have a point he says the key is
to to break up these gangs that he says
are getting away with murder and if you
are successful in breaking up the gangs
um you at least tackle that side of the
problem
well mark i mean you've been reporting
on this issue for many years i'm sure
and i'm sure that you've heard home
secretary after home secretary and prime
minister after prime minister say that
all they need to do is get to the number
of these gangs and this same approach
has failed us and it will continue to
fail us we need a new approach and that
involves taking away the business that
exists for the smugglers and that means
giving people safe routes to come to the
uk and that might mean that it goes
against what this government's um
agenda of hostility has been to date it
might mean that we see a few more people
seeking protection in the uk but if none
of those people were making these
dangerous journeys across the channel in
chaos and were arriving in unregulated
ways but instead they were able to apply
for a visa come safely just the way you
or i would travel from france and join
their family members or the place where
they feel that they'll be safe because
they can speak the language or they have
other connections and seek asylum here
in a in a system that is funded to work
efficiently then that would that would
solve this problem and that would end
our complicity with these smuggling
gangs and it would end these tragedies
like we've seen tonight so when the home
secretary
says
the routes need to be made unviable i
will make the route unviable what do you
think she's
trying to achieve
well i i hope that somebody will ask her
what the assessment that her own
department the home office made of her
bill says about whether this will make
the route unviable her bill is by her
own department's assessment going to
force people to take more dangerous
routes her own department's assessment
says there's no evidence that her
approach will stop people from trying to
cross the channel or make a regular
journeys to the uk we have seen this
approach tried as i say at our own
border for decades the issue of calais
has never gone away no matter how harsh
our home secretaries have been in their
attempts to crack down because as i say
when we try to close off these routes we
lose control of the problem we hand it
to the smugglers
and it results in these horrendous
stories of people dying which nobody in
the uk wants to see the uk is a
compassionate country we want to protect
refugees but we don't want to see this
chaos and we don't want smugglers
getting rich and laughing at us for our
you know desperate efforts to close down
these routes we need to open up more
routes for people to come safely that's
how we take control zoe i just want to
show you some pictures that we have uh
from calais
and
i think we have them in a moment and
this is uh um the latest we have live
pictures in fact from calais and we're
expecting a news conference uh from the
interior minister
gerald darmanin is due to hold a news
conference there shortly and we'll bring
you that just as soon
as we get it
but zoe
i mean clearly
this is a complex issue that is not
going to be quickly solved
yes it is but we're also tired and i'm
sure that we'll hear um you know real
compassion and real sadness from the
mayor of calais and we heard you know
our politicians also saying that this is
such a terrible tragedy and it's such a
complicated issue at the end of the day
these mealy mouth excuses have to stop
we need a change of approach this
approach has failed us and as long as
they keep pushing this failed deterrence
model they are complicit in this
carrying on so i think all of us really
really need to take this moment a
desperately sad moment so many men women
and children whose lives have been lost
for no reason and change our approach
the home secretary needs to step back
and look at what her policies are doing
and it will require whatever solution
is found will require a political
agreement between
um
london and paris between britain and
france which doesn't seem
uh very likely at the moment anyway
well why would the french agree to
simply just take all the refugees who
want to come to the uk and we say to
them we're slightly located to the west
of you and so none of this is our
problem it's all your responsibility
why would they agree to that we have to
step up and take in our fair share
that's what cooperation really means and
if we provide a route for people to
travel safely to the uk from france then
i'm sure that the french will be more
open to real collaboration with us in
order to actually solve this problem i
mean but i so many people argue that the
french have a duty to protect these
people when they arrive in their country
absolutely and the french have a lot to
answer for the treatment of migrants in
the calais region is absolutely a an
international
disgrace and it's a big part of the
reason why people don't feel safe in
france they're left destitute they're
left homeless and even when they're
prevented from taking one journey
they're just dropped off and left again
with no support homeless in the region
and obviously they may well try to make
that journey again so this is a
europe-wide failure um and we are one of
the richest regions in the world and we
have seen this same logic fail time and
time again people die in the
mediterranean people die at the polish
border people are now dying in the
channel and we all need to change our
approach and the uk can take the lead in
that and show that we are actually a
compassionate country that we deserve to
lead the response on this that we will
open our doors to people who are fleeing
persecution and we will let them travel
in a way that is safe and secure and
that doesn't result in these terrible
deaths because people move people will
always move people always have moved we
will not turn off some magical tap will
not find a way to be brutal enough for
people to stop trying to escape danger
and come to our shores
they are numbers that we are perfectly
able to manage if we were trying to
manage them instead we're concocting a
crisis through this same old failed
approach okay
zoe gardner thank you very much for your
time